l'heure est grave nous vivons des heures
bien cela fait maintenant plusieurs
vidéos dans les commentaires ça ne parle
que d'une chose c'est quoi ton espèce de
talent autour du bras qui est excusé
d'être chaud produit la vidéo bas
lorsque user comme toi j'ai effectué des
tonneaux sur le bras droit du bout des
doigts oui j obtiens tatouages et vous
êtes nombreux à part été d'en parler
depuis plusieurs jours alors que moi
même j'en ai déjà parlé dans une vidéo
au sens trahi je sais que vous la
regardiez les vidéos est maire tous les
gens qui sont choqués pour le tatouage
au moins j'étais abonné je te stresse un
peu en regardant une vidéo sur deux soit
fier le cash au fil du temps la garde à
vue parce qu'apparemment il ya les
abonnés qui sont infidèles
montrez-vous là les infidèles ah ouais
effectivement je me suis fait tatouer en
colombie et j'ai fait un blog d'ailleurs
à mon retour et ce passage là sur le
tatouage est d'ailleurs dans le blog et
surtout aujourd'hui il est l'heure de se
faire tatouer sur ces quatre [ __ ]
millions de vues en a peut-être que
100000 qui ont vu que j'avais un
tatouage devez vous contenter du tout le
monde sait ce quiz après vous regardez
plus sa réputation weezy a un tatouage
attend barbe plus tatouage égale squeeze
a changé beaucoup changé et ouais en
quartz n'a pas vu les muscles là bas ils
s'effacent tatouage sur le bras droit
c'est une araignée au nom jarod talent
crabe avec un chapeau c'est quand même
bien plus stylé qu'une araignée
ok je vais le faire les couleurs du
tatouage a changé en ce qui a changé
apparemment c'est surtout la conjugaison
française basse vague les couleurs chose
c'est que déjà je suis en train de
cicatriser donc les couleurs vous
devenir un peu plus fade studio et
surtout utile fait vous jouez la crème
solaire dessus pour le protéger ce qui
fait qu'il est encore plus fade
voilà bientôt ils disparaître a
carrément hashtag squeeze
m ais hashtag avant de dire son truc
c'est que ça pèse tu t'es fait tatouer
moi c'est mieux moi perso je n'aime pas
[ __ ] mais la raison je le savais que
j'étais enceinte certain que je me suis
dit faut que je demande à tous vont
aller ce qu'ils en pensent mais après
chacun ses goûts tu peux pas mettre ces
nuls et chacun ses goûts dans la même
phrase merci de me répondre tu as well
as tu m'as shaft et tu veux que tu
répondes quoi et tu es nous dit où
j'adore ton pseudo tu étais lino au lieu
de perdre votre temps ici lisez des
livres regarder des vidéos plus
intéressante
ah non merci à acheter pour une
prochaine vidéo sur les commentaires et
notes étaient tout à fait juste pas de
tatouage dans tout commentaire s est
passé au le terme votre tatouage temps
ici là je vous jure 2008 y aura des gens
qui liront m c'était aussi des bulles
tatouage de squeeze c'est ce que je me
dis à chaque seconde qui passe depuis
quelques jours ma vie est devenue un
enfer
c'est totalement faux un vrai je m'en
fous je n'accroche pas son tatouage je
crois que je vais me désabonner car ce
tatouage est vraiment bref il est
exaspéré ce qui leurs voisins
2 1 pour toi question qu'est ce qui se
trouve c'est le même mec qui avait dit
pour la barbe j'aime ça doit pas la part
je me désabonne ne se dégage je crois
que je vais arrêter de répondre aux gens
qui parlent de gens tatouages et ce tout
le boss était parti là dessus
alors je te ferai lancer des témoins
d'art kevin aide c'est une bonne idée en
effet tanger en abonnés samwhan c'est
incroyable c'est bien et ce tout fait
comme il te plaira tu es sur la bonne
voie rouge avec un costume de clown pour
faire le moine aux ta vidéo est nul
comme toujours [ __ ] encore augmenté à
jamais dans le mauvais dossier squeeze
tu n'aimes pas les araignées mais il
sait un tatoo d'araignée comment lui
faire qu'on assassine technique utilisée
en hypnose pour suggérer une idée
discrètement à tête de quelqu'un comme
ça dit on plus jamais renier [ __ ] elle
s'est fait une araignée t-rex sur le
bras hu
[ __ ] là on est sûr de la grosse
araignée tiers extrême en plus de
terrain qu'on fait une vidéo sur cette
connerie tout a commencé qu'on a vu le
bloc de colonies où il a fait un pas
tout dans son bras droit à vous êtes
donc des abonnés fidèles
mais après avoir vu les vidéos qui
suivent on a remarqué que le tatouage de
squeeze n'était plus sûr sont adroits et
sur son bras gauche
mais qu'at on a un problème
wahid aux grecs c'est au clown parce que
je m'appelle tatouages sur les bras en
fait c'est un an ouais bah je vais
débuter ce sera réglé fais pas ça vous
dit de nant tu fais pas
bon les amis il est temps de mettre fin
à toutes ces conneries j'espère que tu
n'as plus le gars n'étaient pas mal
d'eau que d'habitude c'était la vidéo
sur le put un tatouage et fallait que je
fasse au dessus comme ça tout le monde
est définitivement courant et on en
parle plus on expédie sa comme on a
expédié la barbe avant application g que
mon frère a pu faire ses petites bénir
de carrick qui le retour d'amélie sur le
tatouage la photo je suis hyper content
qu'on ait fait ça encore une fois et
surtout si certains trouvent veulent se
faire tatouer réfléchissez bien avancée
quand même pas à prendre à la légère
voilà sept otages que j'ai fait pour moi
façon qu'on se fait tatouer pour moi
comme pour n'importe qui c'est pour soi
on s'est adonné choses soient qui
symbolise quelque chose pour nous soit
qui symbolise rien juste pour la beauté
et moi j'aime bien l'esthétique et
j'aime aussi le symbole kader donc je
compte voilà il me plaît à moi c'est
très important j'en ferai sûrement
d'autres plus tard dans ma vie ce samedi
prochain par exemple pourquoi pas voilà
tout est dit inutile d'en parler any
more merci regardez la vidéo portez vous
bien à très bientôt dans une nouvelle 90